good morning John welcome back it is so
nice to have you back your video is
great and you were right like on every
single point no he wasn't
oh hi Hank sock what what he was wrong
on like five major points well it's
technically true but he just got back
and he hasn't made a video in a long
time and you know I'm living to cut him
some slack got him some slack he hasn't
made a video in three weeks he finally
does it and this is what we get you have
to hold him accountable
well Hank success so so here goes first
factually inaccurate point John you have
now made everyone on the internet think
that I did not have a girlfriend in high
school and just ask sherry or Sarah or
the other Sarah or Jenny and all of them
except one of the Sarah's will
definitely tell you that I was their
boyfriend one of the Sarah's was like we
can't use those labels they're arbitrary
I think she also thought that monogamy
was arbitrary you know like not fooling
around with other guys while she was
dating me second thing albert einstein
while not saying many of the things that
people say he said was kind of a
quotation generation machine he said
lots of really beautiful and wonderful
things like in a letter to harry s
truman he said i do not know what
weapons World War three will be fought
with but World War four will be fought
with sticks and stones
he also wrote to a friend do not worry
about your difficulties in mathematics I
assure you that mine are still greater
third the most common internet sent is
not confusing your for you or it is not
exposing yourself on chatroulette and it
is not as you said miss courting
Einstein the most common Internet sin of
course is taking a picture of yourself
with this camera angle because you think
that people will think you're more
beautiful if you have a giant head mmm
there we go that's good fourth I do know
the six types of quarks but I also know
who Amanda Bynes is she's the cute funny
one from hairspray and I have seen
hairspray like five times so there and
to prove to you and the world that
knowledge of elementary particle physics
does not exclude knowledge of teen pop
culture I have written a short song I
want two three four
workers it don't matter you stood out a
man will have tons of boson I think that
they make up everything that we can see
and then we know exist so somewhere out
there a girl's brushing her hair
misquoting Einstein it just isn't fair
Oh elementary particle physics is kind
of confusing but a man too bad she's
sure it's bad so I can't help but sing
go down straight job talk about it if
you don't know what at work is it don't
matter you still got a man with laptop
the boson doesn't emit they make up
everything that we could see and that we
know exists and finally fifth I checked
amanda bynes his twitter and she didn't
say any of the things that you said she
said
apparently you meant oh hello Miranda
finds did tweet those things what not
how did you even know what I was talking
about I don't know yes but seriously she
did write those tweets I mean if I was
going to make up someone misquoting
Albert Einstein why would I choose
amanda bynes she wrote them and then I
guess she deleted them that ruins my
whole thing I was gonna be all witty and
talk about how John put words about
putting words in her mouth in her mouth
and that John you miss quoted her
misquoting that it's all gone now wait
though that means you embarrassed amanda
bynes into deleting her tweets you jerk
the Internet is so weird
let me take this opportunity now that I
know amanda Bynes watches or more likely
just saw an ad reply about it amanda
Bynes we are sorry we think your lovely
big fans and there's nothing wrong with
what you did I mean you miss food at
Albert Einstein saying a lovely thing I
think there is a very good chance that
Albert Einstein does not care at all
because he's dead
and the spirit of good-natured miss
please leave Amanda Bynes your best
wishes in the comments and if you're
feeling especially creative please
misquote John and I below a tribute to
us quotes that we have never said and
then maybe we'll say some of them and
then you'll be right John I will see you
on Friday
don't forget to be awesome